and also from our 8 news now  investigators a jury dropping all  charges against a former nightclub  promoter accused in two sexual assaults  41-year-old jay lynn was charged with  raping two women actually in separate  incidents one in 2015 another in 2017  but his peers found him not guilty  first allegations do happen and we do  have like real victims out there  and they do deserve to to be her and you  know come forward and because those  false allegations it just they hurt  people like me and they heard the real  victims it was painfully obvious that he  was sharing information with them  including after the fact which is not  something you expect someone to do when  they're trying to get away with a rape  Lynn's attorneys adding the two women  withheld information from police and  changed their story